Sonia it's lovely to see you here at
Fright Fest with your film the Berean
sound studio tell me about your role as
a Lenna
so
the secretary of the studio she someone
quite detached from emotions and she's
quite up and arrogant it's not really
helpful as a secretary would be I had so
much fun with that I enjoyed every
minute of it and building up this
character so it was absolutely wonderful
and it's it's a bit stereotypical in my
head it was in order to bring this
character to life and I hope I did a
good job but that's why it's so much fun
to do
she is someone
I think would make people love through
her behavior and response to people's
demands so yeah this is a wonderful
character be like what's Peeta like to
work with as a director he is absolutely
wonderful and what I like about Peter
of course he's acclaimed and acclaimed
director and he's he's really
magnificent but when he went through the
interaction he has with actors what is
so great about him is the fact that he
lets you do your own thing and kid
doesn't interfere with your performance
also it helps you accomplish what you
want to accomplish through the character
and it's absolutely wonderful to have
the freedom to move around and
you know created yourself and what's it
like working with Toby Jones as well
he's just a great actor isn't he he is
absolutely amazing and he's one of the
actors that have always admired very
much because he transforms so easily
from film to film and he you know it was
a big lesson family working with Derby
and the fact that he's so professional
so relaxed and so human and he was one
of them honored honored to be a part of
this film and have until we Jones
great what can we look forward to from
you next Anya
I cannot really talk about it just yet
but thank you so much for asking me the
questions here are those directors that
you really admire out there that if you
want to watch a film you always seek
them out well there's some well some
Mendes was definitely one of them I
really love Spanish cinema I really love
I'm not over you I love film I really
love films and I really hope I'll be
able to continue working in them you
know and moving forward and working with
wonderful directors as I have been
blessed enough to do it so far it's been
lovely to speak to Tania lots of levels
were in sounds to downloads of love with
volunteer as well
you